[Music]
it's morning in kiev
the distant sounds of russian rockets
echo in ukraine's capital
[Music]
foreign
before the war
ruslan yarmolyuk worked as a journalist
but when russian forces encroached on
ukrainian territory he turned in his
camera for a gun
um
rustling is part of a new force that has
assembled to protect ukrainian towns and
cities
while the country's military fights
russian forces on the front lines
civilians have taken up arms to protect
their homes
hungry
the territorial defense is made up
entirely of volunteers some have
previous military training but many do
not
there are businessmen artists and
students who overnight have become
soldiers
[Music]
is training new recruits before the war
she was a police officer and had been a
member of the national guard
foreign
the training is fast just three days
before recruits will be put into
rotation patrolling the streets and
manning checkpoints
it has to be this way because one
hundred thousand ukrainians have
enlisted in the new force
people like olenna who have military
experience are the backbone of the
territorial defense
tasked with preparing civilians for
combating
[Music]
so many ukrainians have enlisted to
fight that there are not enough weapons
to go around
many volunteers spend their time huddled
in bomb shelters preparing molotov
cocktails
they stuff pieces of styrofoam into the
bottles which will act as a thickening
agent when mixed with gasoline it makes
these diy weapons all the more deadly
but the effort to defend kiev goes far
beyond homemade bombs
i'm wearing
the military protection it's very
unusual for me
alexi honsharuk is still getting used to
the gear and the kalashnikov
he's not just any civilian he's a former
ukrainian prime minister the youngest
ever to have the job
early in the war he enlisted in the
territorial defense
though he's not on the front lines he's
helping his fellow soldiers in another
way
aerial intelligence we need to find an
enemy to
control
the movements
and
to make sure that we understand their
logic to make sure that we understand
their tactic and strategy
far from the battlefield it's a side of
the war few people ever see
our cameras gained rare access to the
operations nerve center where they
monitor aerial activity and work to
outwit the russians
so far it appears to be working
ukrainian forces have won strategic
victories in recent weeks and have held
off russian advances towards kiev
despite being outgunned
the city is prepared
i believe
that it's impossible to take control of
your cave
but
as we already learned from previous
couple of weeks
they have
enough weapons to destroy our cities
[Music]
on this morning in the city's west end
russian forces bombed this 16-story
apartment building
[Music]
[Applause]
emergency crews saved this woman and her
family from their burning apartment
is another apartment building in a
nearby suburb was also targeted
daria is a member of the ukrainian
military she was on shift when missiles
hit the building
she returned to find her home partially
destroyed
it's
[Music]
russian forces continue to bomb
residential buildings schools and
hospitals across ukraine
large cities like mariupol and harkiv
have been reduced to rubble
in kiev the same ruthless tactic is
being used
um
as the war enters its sixth week there's
an air of conviction on the streets of
the capital
russia had hoped for a swift victory but
alexi says that plan failed to take into
account the will of a people defending
their homeland
cave is a symbol very important symbol
but the real value of ukraine
people ukrainian people